i'm digging the wallpaper in your
background there
thank you very much
it seems as if i plastered it for this
press junker but it's actually been up
here a while
awesome
well when this came your way with all of
the great messages that this story
contains what most excited you about the
project that made you want to do it
because it's just such a sweet fun story
um i think
ultimately first and foremost it's a you
know a celebration of australia and um i
was particularly homesick at the time i
was sent the script so i think i just
sort of devoured it and i love that it
was sort of like a story about these
really unlikely heroes like a taipan
snake and you know a spider and a
scorpion and i feel like kind of the
creepier characters or creatures rather
don't get to be main characters in
movies
so that was fun and also maddie's a
great character this film has been
described as a love letter to australia
so what would you say the film gets
right about australia and the way that
it represents australia
um
i think it's well it's i like to think
we australians are very funny and the
film is hilarious
it has a lot of adventure which one gets
when one travels to australia and all
the incredible landscapes i think the
outback it looks just it's just spot on
um and i think that you know
you know the fact that it's a cast of
kind of aussies that you know i
personally am a big fan of you know guy
pierce eric banner
uh jackie weaver kylie minogue
um i
i definitely feel like uh it gets it
kind of gets everything right for me um
yeah
is it really the only downside of doing
something like this the fact that you
don't get to work physically alongside
all of those people in the cast yeah
yeah i mean i think the downside too is
particularly for comedy that if you have
like obviously the other actor in front
of you then you can kind of improvise
and there's a lot of like that
communication that's non-verbal where
you kind of pick up the other person's
cue that they might be about to you know
do a bit and you can't really do that
obviously when you're on you know zoom
um so that would have been the only uh
downside but i really enjoyed this
process i found uh claire and harry
kripps our directors to be very
collaborative and um yeah it's just like
it's always fun you get to go into your
imagination and and play in a character
yeah what was it like working with two
directors on this do they each bring
something different to the project or
were they always on the same page with
the project no they were always on the
same page and there was only twice in
all the sessions that i did that either
claire or harry wanted one more take one
more version for a line um but i feel
like they uh they definitely shared the
same vision
at what point did you get to see what
maddie would look like what was your
reaction to seeing her does that help
your performance at all
yeah so right away i got was sent the
script and the lookbook for the
characters so i knew um you know how it
was gonna look and uh yeah and i just
thought she was so adorable i couldn't
take it she just was so cute
yeah i mean it's it's so funny how cute
you find yourself going like all these
these little creatures are so cute when
they're supposed to be like so evil and
scary and i mean i get that's the point
of the movie but they're just adorable
they're so adorable but it's nice that
it proves that you know just that just
because you're different doesn't mean
you're not beautiful and i loved all the
messages of
you know embracing someone's inner
beauty and and
and and sort of family being who you
journey with not just um you know who
you're born with and not to judge a book
by its cover and to put aside your
differences and that home is where the
heart is i thought there were just so
many you know as a mom i sort of read
the script and thought oh this would be
a great um
you know a great story to tell and it
would give lots of opportunities for um
conversations about things that you know
you would want to organically bring up
with small with small people
what's it like to hear yourself bring an
animated character to life is it easier
to watch an animated movie that you've
done than when you do live action
it's so much easier to watch an animated
movie because you're not having to look
at your own face
although sometimes i you know listening
to myself when i have to go back and
listen to interviews is not always fun
so
i'm with you all the way i don't think
there's anybody that likes listening to
their voice or seeing their face
personally i mean maybe i'm wrong but i
think
it's always challenging
what was it like to get to sing a little
song for this too is that fun was it
exciting was it scary
so terrifying and i begged harry and
claire knight i said please please can't
somebody else sing this song it
shouldn't be me i can't sing i'm gonna
ruin the movie and they said please isla
and so i had to record it and
some members of the family that will
remain unnamed laughed very hard at my
rehearsal process uh but i tried to
remain courageous like maddie and i
recorded it and then when i heard it
actually in the movie i thought oh
you can't really tell it sounds fine
i love that each of these characters
have their own quirks and and their own
insecurities
personally do you feel most like maddie
or do you think you're more like any one
of the other characters
um i think growing up as a redhead in
australia with an english accent um i
definitely felt like adolescence was you
know i think you know in the same way
that maddie is sort of um
well you know maddie sort of
doesn't sort of you know it's hard for
her to accept her differences at the
beginning you know because obviously she
has
you know she was conditioned to believe
that she was this horrible thing and
then really she grows to learn to love
you know herself and be empowered by
what's on the inside and i think like
you know a lot of us who you know looked
a little different than our peers during
adolescence it was it it's an it's a
it's a it's a
it's a similar journey to kind of come
to a place where you go yeah it's i'm
i'm used to my red hair now and it's
what makes me different
what's next for you are you currently
working on something do you know what
the next project is
uh i completed a uh television show
called wolf like me um
alongside josh gad directed by abe
forsythe um produced by made up stories
um and i believe that's coming out in
january um it's a limited series um on
peacock and i play a very unusual
character again so i'm excited for
people to see that
what was the fun of getting to work
alongside josh yeah because he seems
like he would just bring a lot of fun to
every day at work
josh brings so much fun to every day he
is the kindest and most um you know
collaborative fun scene partner and i
really enjoyed working with him
what do you think life was like for
maddie after this film do you think she
goes on to embrace both sides of herself
the the sweet and the scary side a
little bit better
i think she ends up acclimating to the
outback and actually becomes pretty wild
i could see maddie as being someone who
finally you know being raised in sort of
you know in captivity since she was an
egg and having a chance to sort of
connect with her
home country kind of you know going a
little having a lot of fun let's just
say that
from the first time that you've read
this script until the finished project
that we see now
was there any standout story or
character changes along the way or do
things stick pretty close to what you
first
read i feel like the relationship
between pretty boy and maddie actually
evolved um
a lot during the course of uh
us
shooting this um i know that moment in
the blue mountains where they kind of
have developed empathy for each other
and maddie realizes that in order to
have somebody um accept her for who she
is she needs to extend the same to him
and truly understand what his experience
is as you know being so beautiful and
and sort of being treated you know being
judged for his outside exterior like she
is instead of their interior and i think
that scene and their relationship was
definitely um
something that seemed to grow deeper as
we uh worked on the story
do you think he'll also be changed now
he won't go back to his old ways after
this experience with her
yeah i think that even the pretty boy
will always be a sort of spoiled celeb
um who's depended on how many likes he
gets on instagram
um i think now he sees others for who
they really are he's through his
relationship with maddie and their
friendship and because he's equally
trapped and kind of marginalized but on
the other end of the spectrum and i
think that once he's seen
through that window into her experience
i'm sure he'll he'll be a different
koala bear moving forward
are you somebody who normally like how
do you normally feel about these kinds
of snakes and spiders and scorpions
these sorts of things are you someone
who is like honest or terrified i will
just tell you now i can't even hear the
word spider without getting the kidney
i recently uh stayed in a house in
australia where uh a
mummy spider gave birth to many many
many spiders um and they covered uh
the
sort of the
ceiling of uh of my bedroom and it was
definitely not the most fun time let's
just say that no i would have burned
down the building so thank you
thank you so much for talking to me
about this thank you